today we have been analyzing the
situation after the Berlin conference
and how can the European Union engage
more forcefully and after analyzing the
situation and several hypotheses of what
can happen in the next days we are
charged the working bodies of the
council the cops
we're the new ambassadors sitting to
present to the council concrete
proposals on how to implement this
ceasefire and enforcing the UN arms
embargo cervical and deposit CT appoo
totally symmetrical achieved at the g5
this device he'll organize a al
initiative the president from say news
even fail like instead you know Hodgins
absolutely the situation say not Mamata
Grady empirical evidence of the tumor is
a meta status so la sombra de la razón
aqui the psyche liberal law some lady
Peaks on Aleph and Azhar knew something
exactly le domaine de la securite entre
misión de política security defense
communi reconcile shortly Samhita capo
on Monty said copious on strategic
the consejo pea shop jelly okay present
oh yeah la commissioner hope n magic OC
am one tonk a vice-presidency a Listeria
the syrup on TV news a supreme asaji the
development diplomacy climatic the
facade set ambition conducive on so a
package a public peace on the grounds
limit given let her uncle please
dolly video Sansa not refer to a fuss or
difficulty Matic sappy about the
succession ooh Mississippi hapara
elation global you know hope a new genre
sellin em Fox on the division memc the
man who you see supreme a tooth no
division Sebastian Koch like a travail
owns rest on long before every monk like
on Trent a climatic science critters on
to traction international to Union
European Akuma sipping a trade
agreements
sanap Ibaka - sounds ok aunty em pack
aunt
LeConte Renta climatic Dan is a [ __ ]
commercio a new face on I've been you
forming my colleagues about my meetings
with Iranian Foreign Minister Zarif last
Thursday in Delhi and where we had a
frank dialogue including the latest
development around the jcpoa and the
ministers remember me that had a mandate
to engage with all relevant actors in
the region in order to analyze the
situation created after the last events
and which can be the future of the jcpoa
the minister of the three countries
Germany France United Kingdom who have
asked me to launch the process of the to
solve the dispute about the nuclear deal
have insisted on the fact that the
purpose of doing so is true safeguard
this deal not to substitute it by
another deal today I will come the
initiative or some Member State many of
them France Netherlands Denmark Belgium
Italy Portugal Greece and Germany
regarding the creation of an Adu pian
LED maritime surveillance mission in the
Strait of Hormuz I want to welcome this
contribution to the distillation in the
region and to ensure a safe navigation
environment finally also very much in
the current issues we are we have been
discussing the new Turkish illegal
drilling in the eastern Mediterranean
where we received an update by the
Cypriot Foreign Minister another one
another list and not update and we
agreed to ask to the relevant Council
working party relics to take forward and
finalise the work on leasing listing
listing no listen listing of persons and
entities involved in these illegal
activities in order to implement the
decisions taken about sanctions